worried about what questions to ask
during an interview this video is for
you
welcome back this is episode 21 of
Udacity career tips my name is Martin
McGovern and today we are digging into
our community questions
Venkata asks how can I avoid asking bad
questions at the end of an interview on
the flip side what is considered to be a
good question to ask at a behavioral
interview this is a great question so
let's dig in right now the first thing
you need to know is that you're allowed
to prepare your questions before an
interview you don't have to wait till
the end of the interview to come up with
all of your questions personally I like
to go in with at least five questions
written down and ready to go before I
even get there that way at the end of
the interview when they open it up for
questions if I draw a blank boom I've
got them right there ready to go now
when it comes to what questions to ask
you should be asking open-ended
questions questions that are yes/no or
require one word to respond typically
kill the conversation and lead to
awkward silences so the questions that
you're gonna want to ask are ones that
show that you have a genuine curiosity
about the company the industry the role
and the person that you're talking to
maybe it would help if I gave a few
examples here's what not to ask do you
have a work from home policy it's a
pretty selfish question
and it's one that has a very short
answer and really doesn't help move the
interview along when do promotions
happen this is a weird one because of
course you want to know when you're
gonna get performance reviews and stuff
you haven't even gotten the offer yet so
why are you asking about promotions how
many days do I get off for vacation and
sick leave again we are in the interview
process you haven't even gotten the
offer yet so asking questions about when
you get to not work before you even get
told you're allowed to work is a bit
weird
these questions are selfish dead-ends
and short-sighted they make it seem like
you only care about money and perks and
you come off as someone who really
doesn't care about the role at all most
of these nuts and bolts questions are
going to be answered once you get the
offer so don't jump the gun instead
let's ask questions like what skills do
you think would make someone successful
in this role this is a great question
because you're asking their opinion
you're involving them in your question
so they get to actually give you a real
answer that's not just yes or no
will success be measured in this role
this is a great question because you get
insights into the metrics you're gonna
be evaluated on and if you've been
evaluated against those metrics in the
past you have a prime opportunity to
bring in more evidence tell another
story and prove that you're right for
this role what is it that you like most
about this company and the work you do
wow we are really involving the
interviewer in this question we're
actually getting them to get excited and
if you can get them talking excitedly
about what they do they're gonna leave
that interview feeling great about
themselves and great about the
conversation you just had with them
which puts you in a better light when
they're thinking back about hiring you
two days from now and now the most
important question you should always ask
at the end of every interview what do
the next steps in the interview process
look like now we're thinking ahead now
we're trying to move towards the next
step in the process and we get to gauge
if they're seemingly wanting to bring us
to that next stage all of these
questions show that you care about the
role want to perform well and respect
the interviewers time and perspectives
they open up the conversation to let you
build or provide more examples and they
just make you seem smart at the end of
the day so do your research hit up
Google and you type in best questions to
ask at the end of an interview you will
find thousands of examples and all you
need are 5 to 10 - right onto your
notepad and bring in to crush it in your
interview
thank you so much for watching I love
answering your questions and sharing as
many resources I can for you to be
successful in your job search if there's
any other topics you'd like us to dive
into please throw them in the comments
below and I'll be addressing them in
future videos also if you know anyone
searching for a job right now tag them
and let them know you're thinking about
them maybe it will help them in their
search as for us that's all the time we
have so I'll be seeing you during the
next Udacity career tip thanks again
I'll see you next time